Hi, my name is Jason Cornwell and I'm a User Experience Designer on Gmail.
We've been hard at work to update Gmail with a new look...
...and I'm excited to share with you some of the biggest improvements.
To start, we've completely redesigned the look and feel of Gmail...
...to make it as clean, simple and intuitive as possible.
In addition, the new Gmail automatically adapts to fit nicely in any size window.
If you prefer a specific display density, you can easily set that as well.
Some people use a lot of labels, others chat a lot.
You can now adjust the size of the label and chat areas to meet your needs.
Even if you do nothing, Gmail adapts to you.
The new look allows themes to really shine.
We've updated many of them with new high-resolution imagery.
You may want to take a moment to check out one of the many new high-definition themes.
Conversations in Gmail have been redesigned to improve readability...
...and to feel more like a real conversation.
We've also added profile pictures so that you can see who said what.
Searching is at the heart of Gmail.
The new search box makes it easy to customize your search and find exactly what you're looking for.
You can also create a filter right from the search box.
We're excited to finally share the new Gmail with you...
...and hope you'll enjoy the new design as much as we do.